Speaker 1: The misfortunes continue for Mehmet
Oz, the TV doctor turned Pennsylvania Senate
candidate. We already knew that he wasn't doing so
well in the polls, down by as many as 11 points to
Democrat John Fetterman. And he, of course, had
his crew to take grocery store video go viral. He
also got caught lying about how he supposedly only
has two homes when he actually has ten. But now,
one of his most important allies in the race,
Donald Trump, is seemingly giving up on him. And
making matters worse is Fox News, which is also
piling on. According to sources at Rolling Stone,
Trump has said about Oz, quote, he's going
to f ing lose. Trump is also dumbfounded that
someone who has been popular on TV for so long
is performing so poorly. But really, Trump should
just look at a mirror on that one since he was
losing in the polls for much of the 2016 and 2020
election cycle. So it can happen, right? Trump
asked his advisers whether the polls may be skewed
or phony, and they've had to tell him things like,
this is not a matter of the polls being rigged.
They are just major problems with the campaign
and specifically with Dr. Oz as a candidate.
Trump also doesn't get veterans appeal to
voters. He thinks that he's in poor shape and he
spends too much time in the basement just like
Joe Biden did. Apparently, Trump just doesn't get
why people would prefer an everyman caller type
dude over an elitist multimillionaire in Dr. Oz.
Trump, however, hasn't completely given up on
the race yet because he's going to be heading
over to Pennsylvania on September 3rd to do a
rally for Oz and also for Republican gubernatorial
candidate Doug Mastriano. Now, if that rally
gets canceled sometime between now and then,
that's going to mean that Trump realizes there is
no hope and that's going to be the coup de gras
in the race. Mastriano Mastriano also is down
somewhere between ten and 15 points, so Trump
may at some point decide to pull the parachute.
And then you'll know that this race is over,
as well as the gubernatorial race. And it's not
just Trump turning away from Oz. Even Fox News
is doing it. They ran a segment on Dana Perino
show last week covering Dr. Oz's latest gaffes,
the Crudity video. Fetterman trolling Oz in
a number of different ways. And it was just a
very unbalanced take. You'd think that Fox News
would give the advantage to the Republican as
to how things went between the two candidates.
But when you look at this segment, you realize,
no, they're kind of just piling on on Dr. Oz's
misfortunes. Let's take a look at the clip.
Speaker 3: In a viral video, you see Dr. Oz, he's
walking around a grocery store where he's talking
about how inflation is really hitting Americans
hard and it's making things more expensive in
grocery stores, especially that crudity.
Speaker 2: But it isn't grocery shopping.
I'm at Wagner, and my wife wants some
vegetables for today. Guys, that's $20
for day. And this doesn't include the tequila.
Speaker 3: Now, Fetterman attacked Dr. Oz on
Twitter as being out of touch, noting most people
in Pennsylvania call it a veggie tray and the
supermarket chain is called Wegmans, not Wag.
Nurse and Fetterman raised over $500,000 in just
24 hours while giving out Wagner's Let Them Eat
Crudity bumper stickers. Dr. Oz said, look, he was
exhausted campaigning when he made the video in
April, and sometimes he even gets his kids names
wrong. Then Fetterman attacked Dr. Oz for owning
ten properties with a photo of a monopoly board
with ten homes on one space. Tweeting P.O.V.,
you are Dr. Oz playing a board game. He then
noted that Monopoly was invented in New Jersey.
A swipe at Dr. Oz for having lived in Jersey
for three decades now, Dr. Oz responded, saying,
I purchased my homes with my money. You lived off
your parents until you were almost 50. Get off
the couch, John. Now, look, this is a battle
over likability. The latest Fox News poll shows
Fetterman is viewed favorably by 49% of voters.
Dr. Oz is viewed unfavorably by 55% of voters.
Speaker 1: And so they really got to everything
in that little segment, didn't they? They got to
the grocery store gaffe. John Fetterman response
to it with the veggie tray. And then they got into
the monopoly board and the ten houses on Boardwalk
and how Monopoly was invented in New Jersey. And
sure, they show Dr. Oz with that tweet trying to
fire back, but it fell flat. Obviously, Fetterman
has gotten the best out of these exchanges,
and he knows the troll game a lot better than
Mehmet Oz does. So that's the latest on this race.
It's been one of the most entertaining races to
follow. And we can't just call Dr. Oz completely
out of this at this point. Everyone has to vote.
But we'll see if the trend continues in this
direction and if veterans able to really squash
him by going up 15, maybe 20 points in the polls,
then we can start celebrating a little bit
early, I'd say. But everyone has to vote and
it's not a sure fire thing just yet. But things
are definitely looking good for John Fetterman.